is with us in California
hi ad how are you I'm doing fine mr.
Anthony thank you for accepting my car
my pleasure how can I help I am 62 I
plan to retire at 67 I'm a licensed
independent contractor I have my real
question is I have about $200,000 in
collectible comic books I've been
collecting comic books from the 90s and
I'm wondering my original plan was to
sell these in after I retired as just a
supplemental income however I'm thinking
of selling them before my question is
should I sell them now or should I wait
till I retire I'm pretty much debt-free
I do have a mortgage three hundred
thousand my home is worth about five
hundred and fifty thousand and other
than that I'm debt free well done and
your nest egg is what size not counting
the comic books I have about sixty
thousand in a couple of different IRAs
Roth and I have so the vast majority of
your at worth is in in the comic books
exactly okay well my guess is that not
only do you have this collection but
you're probably an expert a self-made
expert to have a collection that size
and to actually know what they're worth
and so I believe in it for many years
yeah you probably have gotten a
reasonably good rate of return on them
to date and you probably are be in a
better position than I am to ascertain
what they will go up in value as a
category collectibles whatever you want
to drop into that bucket cars comic
books art doesn't keep up with good
mutual funds or real estate as a
category now the caveat to that is most
people
don't stay on top of their hobby enough
to make it make the kind of money that
an investment will investment will make
it just sits there and passively does
whatever it does and I've had this Joe
DiMaggio baseball card for 46 years and
now it's worth X or whatever that kind
of thing right but they never really
they didn't really manage it like you
would manage investments and so
consequently they don't now some people
I've got a friend that has probably
probably a million dollars in
collectible cars he's a
multi-billionaire and he is so into
these cars and he's so into making money
on it
even though he doesn't need the money
but it's just like a game to him that he
actually makes a great rate of return
messing around with these collectible
cars but that's because he's he's
neck-deep in it all the time he's
messing with it all the time if you want
to continue to do that you might make
more on these than you would make just
investing the money in mutual funds or
then you would make by paying off your
house with the money or something like
that but but whoever comes along after
you is probably not going to do well
because they don't have your expertise
in liquidating them all of that to say
unless you just love messing with it on
a daily basis so much I'd probably
liquidate it or at least the vast
majority of it mmm okay the people
coming out you know I because I've been
thinking of selling some of them you
know just kind of I'm getting too many
almost yeah yeah and you know what I
would do is say I'm going to keep 10% my
favorite 10% okay or and that may mean
not numbers of dollars that might be
numbers of books I don't know but I have
a firearm collection that I have
thoroughly enjoyed building the firearm
collection and it's probably worth a
little more than your comic books give
or take but and but I know what each of
those guns are worth where they came
from I know the history on them and it's
just kind of I got into it you know like
you did with a comic books and so
however even though my sons and
sons-in-law will enjoy shooting those
weapons they would not be able to
maximize the value dollar-wise of those
things because they don't know them and
know what they're worth
upon my death so upon my death the value
of that collection will go down because
the knowledge of that collection dies
with me even if I brought a half a book
on the stupid thing so that's what's the
problem is with your situation
you hold exclusive keys to the knowledge
that make this valuable are largely
valuable I would Lee I would get rid of
a bunch of it on that basis